we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's go next to our caller from the
three-two-three area code 3 to 3 tell us
who you are where you're calling from I
David calling from Amsterdam actually
but from Los Angeles and my question is
maybe not the most relevant but I've
been wanting to ask you this for a while
mm-hmm it's regarding Hillary Clinton of
all things okay and I'm sure you're
aware as everyone is it's it's really a
prevalent idea that she was you know in
the election just one of two evils and
yeah Trump was bad but she was also bad
and yep she's corrupt and all this and
I've noticed on your show I watch your
show quite a bit and it seems like you
were advocating for her over Trump but
yet not really that supportive of her
and but yet I haven't really quite seen
specific criticisms and I just wanted to
ask you if you could list out maybe your
your top criticisms of her for why you
were not excited about her as a
presidential yeah so listen I mean I I
want to direct one thing I was
completely clearly saying you should
vote for Hillary Clinton in the general
election like there was no hesitation
whatsoever so my main critiques of
Hillary Clinton and I won't go to like a
sub bulleted list because it's almost
two years past the election at this
point but her economic policy is way too
far to the right for me right so the the
pulling teeth nature of just even
getting her to come around on some
minimum wage increases on her college
idea which was still not what Bernie
Sanders is was on health care
she's just economically to the right of
me she also on foreign policy is well to
the right of me and I didn't find her to
be genuine so I mean that those are very
like overarching things but and we could
break those down further but I think
that the most important question about
Hillary Clinton right now is consider
all of the areas that we were warned
about Hillary were actually Trump's the
guy we have to be concerned with right
what's going to happen to the middle
class will look at Trump's tax cut and
the disaster that it is Hillary's going
to get us into a bunch of wars
Trump was asking about invading
Venezuela right and and most importantly
the Supreme Court no-one even if you
felt that Hillary and Trump overlapped
90 percent which I would argue they
didn't but even if you really felt that
there was just not a significant
difference who can argue that Hillary
Clinton would have taken the to Supreme
Court picks so far and appointed for
life people like Neil Gorsuch and in
particular Brett Kavanaugh so so I think
that that is really the more interesting
Hillary Clinton story today in 2018
would you say that she's not genuine
though do you can you elaborate on that
yeah I I feel as though all we get from
Hillary Clinton are the political ideas
that she most recently got the
impression would help her win an
election or win votes I I don't really
feel as though what we get from Hillary
Clinton or her personally held positions
on issues I think if I could just throw
in one quick second question do you
think that ben shapiro is a good example
of a conservative show host as genuine
and intellectually honest of a person
that you can get on the conservative
side or who's an assassin for you if
you're gonna listen to if you're gonna
listen to david pakman and someone on we
can serve it aside who do you think it's
the most intellectually honest person to
listen to and would you think this is so
dangerous for me to say yes to because
intellectually honest and argues in good
faith are not exactly the same thing and
i don't know the answer to that i really
don't know the answers I'd have to think
about it before I say I that's a big
declaration to say the most
intellectually honest person on the
right is ben shapiro i'm certainly not
ready to say that today but i appreciate
hearing from our viewers in amsterdam i
do have to move on a lot of people
holding but I do appreciate the call